[Music]
and Good Samaritan years
I like those people submitted by the
noble Somalian citizen oh good job guy a
new rural Canada log is legal immunity
that people who report drug overdoses
that's good jover doses yes who do you
mean when you want when you when you're
doing heroin with your best friend and
then they're starting to die but you
don't want to go to jail because you're
[ __ ] high as a mother ass that you
don't want to call the Popo but now with
this like hey my buddy dog yes I'm high
come pick me up
they come over and they're like I can't
go to jail because guess what I save
Julia's life for doing harrell and she
was overdosing BAM
I like this who helps you like care for
each other you know I was like a country
in people yep that's pretty dumb how
could people check just do drugs
that doesn't make you eventually look
like Smeagol because you're the best one
oh yeah I don't been a rock [ __ ] you up
yeah it's just heroin just makes you
just really it's like the ring takes
over your whole life I never did heroin
yes pakora well you know I never took it
and I think I regret it a little bit you
wish you did heroin no cause like the
needle part scares the [ __ ] out of me I
didn't for me if you guys like I wish I
had more I had a lot of experiences as a
kid but I wish I had more another one
was also no look that's one thing I wish
I went to jail I wish oh there I'll make
it is that's what I'm saying I wish I
did a lot more stuff but since I did it
I can't do that anymore and I can't even
explore that I know the responses the
amount of negative to positive is like
so much different just focus on this
bracket already been done that so you
you've climbed to say you would have got
that if you did that no cuz what I'm
saying is like so like because I of my
agent upbringing I had a perfect SAT at
one point have I been to jail no that's
what I'm talking about I don't I don't
need that [ __ ]
it's like kayaking you could do that at
any age skydiving any age illegal [ __ ]
you can't
do under 18 like I've been playing the
piano when I was five
I'm tired of that [ __ ] I want to Jack a
car you just said you want to learn how
to play the piano again
you exactly what I'm saying is that
classical bullsh I'm trying to play that
easy ass contemporary pop music [ __ ]
like [ __ ] the covers on YouTube
that's one kind of nerd but back then I
already been done playing that classical
sheet that nobody understands so now I
need to go to jail yep that's not
talking about a balanced like oh [ __ ]
lost a balance like they're not balanced
life I dunno what about what the [ __ ]
are you talking about how did you trade
me a present I'm talking about I wish I
did Harrell any time Joe agrees with you
just know that you sound [ __ ] crazy
nope what well then I'm gonna sound
crazy because I kind of agree with you a
little bit to know what because only for
the experience of it I can experience it
and not have any repercussion like I
wasn't even real imagine there's a time
machine right you could give in a time
machine go back do some [ __ ] and it's
not gonna affect anything the way it is
now Barry wouldn't do it no point in
thinking like that golden horses that's
America there's no consequences I
wouldn't do heroin a scenario I agree
with Barbara in like real life no I
wouldn't I wouldn't want to try her it
was like something not as crazy but like
Kyle like hey want to do some biking in
and you're not even in pain okay I got
some vicodin and my arms not broken
haha I tried - I don't want your [ __ ] I
think my drug conscious wait what the
[ __ ]
really biking is crazy I enjoy seeing my
I mean it just it just felt like I was
relaxed my roommate you had like your
whole [ __ ] face pulled out and is
when he got subscribe by kidding yeah
extra pills we decided to drop it
together on him feel [ __ ] you are a
loser no I thought it was Christmas -
let me take that when I was nursing and
Isaac was getting the vicodin
it's not going to look like boys nothing
like me
is there certain drugs that don't affect
that so so it could have been one of
those no yeah something like it's crazy
that vicodin apparently didn't affect it
remember you have contractions you
should you smoke a cigarette it overlaps
ha ha ha ha ha no no you like that no
I'm saying I'm giving you good advice
that's true cuz whenever you want a
doctor to do a little bit extra
everyone knows go to Mexico there's that
one veterinarian that called himself a
doctor and you'll do all kinds of [ __ ]
Oh everyone knows to go to the Chinese
one we talking about no they always get
their boobie butt jobs in Mexico
specifically Tijuana though you have to
be specific
that's all of Mexico rest in peace uh
Kanye West's mom she went to TJ she went
to Mexico I believe for because and no
doctor in the states would do it because
they said you were going to be hurting
from it or die from it
and she went I believe to get one Mac
and then they got done oh man trying to
worse it is vanity people it ain't worth
it my friend used to get ketamine in
Tijuana all the time you can get
anything you want in Mexico children
Amanda fun I don't condone drug use I'm
just saying from experience I could talk
about it and I don't listen to Joey
I tell you just right now I didn't do a
single drug and I turned out perfectly
fine Macky Davis balance yeah that was
fun I just wanted curious if I was
carriers I probably would have done it
you were carry when you see your friends
pass out and their lips are purple you
never went how does that feel like
listen you know what stuff oh you know
what [ __ ] stuff though because I
wasn't curious I always had to take care
of everybody dude it was [ __ ]
annoying
I thought it was food get annoying dude
you never saw your friend go purple in
front of you and [ __ ] throw up and
almost die on their own throw up come on
man that's good time that's what I got
to take care of
[Music]
anyway so the Canadian government they
don't have this neutral it's called the
Good Samaritan drug over the
and so they're ensuring that anyone that
calls 911 or in a case of an emergency
or someone overdosing no one everyone
there it has immunity in terms of
getting prosecuted for possession so if
they're at a party and somebody but the
has their limits then they can call the
police and the police not going to
investigate what's up so you're going to
investigate they're saying that they're
going to just have immunity from simple
drug possession charges or violations of
parole probation or pretrial release
orders but other offenses like
trafficking or driving while impaired
are not expensive something man you're
lucky you're not in the [ __ ]
Philippines the third day dude you'll
[ __ ] blast your face off of that [ __ ]
dude
I suppose that's body boom dead scary so
Canada they have like a really big
opiate problem just like here in the US
especially like you know was heroin gone
crazy a lot of like a lot of that like
hundreds of deaths I do too
fatally overdosing on heroin and stuff
so that's why they enacted this law to
hopefully obviously it's not going to
solve the problem but at least what I
just did a lot of drugs and I've been in
a drug wolf I just never knew anyone
that did heroin
no because when I think of this epidemic
and heroin and whatever use right
like I guess he like that is the last
resort drug like you're under the
freeway you're [ __ ] ending up with
Abe needles and [ __ ] and you're just
[ __ ] around a burning trash can and
that's all you care about people like
the Red Hot Chili Peppers plays in the
background
I'm Bridge yeah in Harran the most
extreme for John I just feel like heroin
is the last resort drug like but I don't
know you're the most out of cannot alter
it might be it might be a part of a
different culture like I don't know like
goth culture I don't know I might be
[ __ ] burning my own [ __ ] self by
saying that [ __ ] but it might be a part
of a different group
kind of like kind of like the Racine
right now it's just like alcohol coke
and [ __ ] like pills like that it's a
lifestyle yeah and then like I don't
know the asian girl that needs to study
scene is the adderall and Buckett
methamphetamines and like it's just
different I think it's different so I
don't know what this heroin world is and
where this epidemic is happening because
I can identify a [ __ ] Tweaker I could
identify a crackhead I could identify a
STONER a heroin person not my world
dude have you guys seen well if you guys
go did you guys ever visit the great
city of La and you [ __ ] it god damn it
what's not right now baby what sometimes
you're not always always
David God we all know it's not true it's
always all the way they know it's not
always you're like my father is all
wrong you think you have a Florida stand
on I am having a quarter set up because
it's usually Jose or the last three
times yeah thank you in your face such a
loyal [ __ ] men [ __ ] all you
[ __ ] it was yeah
what were you saying anyway but God God
man if you guys have ever been to
beautiful Los Angelos you guys ever go
to beautiful Los Angeles California you
go to this place called Skid Row you'll
see something called you'll see
something called a Tweaker later the
crackhead beam is [ __ ] dope what this
seems like they're falling but somehow
they don't fall have you ever like
believe thank you Billy like Michael
Jackson other pets their feet it's
[ __ ] insane dude it's sorcery Skid
Row has an interesting culture everyone
bicycle has a stereo duct tape to it
shuttle and it'll bump yeah they got
some good I seen people in a [ __ ]
wheelchair which took one speaker like
speech and their legs work yeah you can
delay as I look difficulty that's so
true
crazy I like Skid Row could you get your
home you can relate to them so well you
better not be missing no just kidding
news uploads so go down and subscribe
for our channel so you can see more
video okay and there's another one up
here check it out
I
[Music]